he was a legend on the pitch
a controversial but inspirational figure
off it
tens of thousands mourned his death last
week from a heart attack age 60.
he's gone but no one is letting him be
forgotten
this came from our fanaticism from our
love for diego
a commemoration that could help improve
the country's economic situation
this is the note designed by some of his
most ardent fans
who have launched a campaign on
change.org appealing to the president
and the central bank
to issue a 10 000 peso note worth about
124 dollars
what we are seeing is is how people you
know is
reacting in a way uh that
brings you know maradona back you know
to the
the center of the scene uh with with
something
uh a very concrete and
and very symbolic
such as a banknote now with the economy
weakened by debt inflation and lack of
foreign investment
argentina needs him again
it could be an interesting boost to the
argentine economy imagine the central
bank accumulating reserves this way
with interest from abroad to generate
dollars
the petition has so far attracted more
than 20 000 signatures and is growing
rapidly
it's clear that many argentines still
don't want to let diego maradona go
to put his face this face on a banknote
would put him on a pedestal with the
country's founding fathers
with a vita a figure transcending sport
and inspiration beyond the football
pitch
with his death argentina has been
analyzing and appreciating what maradona
gave them during his life
the most poignant being the 1986 world
cup
however the bank will be asking whether
maradona who made and squandered
millions
is an appropriate symbol of monetary
good sense
others will point to his drug problems
and treatment of women
but it's for what he did on the pitch
that most want to remember him
a great inspiration and very emotional
it brings a tear to my eye just talking
about him
as his legend grows his followers now
hope his image will continue to inspire
them
from beyond the grave daniel shrimler al
jazeera
buenos aires